- Oh wow, it smells amazing in here.
Did you just make curry?
- No, uh, spaghetti.
- Spaghetti and like, curry?
- No, just spaghetti, spaghetti.
- Are you sure?
It smells like Masala.
- Woo.
- What's up?
- You just chillin' on
your magic carpet or what?
- Has anyone ever told
you, you look like that
Indian actress, what's her name?
Priyaka Chopra.
- Oh, Tinder. Avoiding
an arranged marriage?
- So is it like The Bachelor?
An arranged marriages, you
just give somebody a rose?
- You know who else you look like?
Mindy Kaling.
- Dude, has anybody ever told you
you like just like Aziz Ansari.
- That's messed up.
- Dude, no seriously.
- I only swipe right on exotic women.
- Thanks for the ride man.
- Dude, what the hell.
- You're my Uber driver.
- Jack, we work together.
- Oh IT guy, you fix computers.
- You know I don't do
a whole lot of reading.
- Oh, you don't say.
- But I am a scholar when
it comes to the Kama Sutra.
- Ugh
(water splashing)
- My mustache.
(International music)